-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy- and
Tony Award-winning actor
you know from movies like
"The Birdcage"
and "The Lion King," as well as
shows like "The Gilded Age"
and "Only Murders
in the Building."
He's currently starring
in "Pictures from Home"
on Broadway's Studio 54.
And you can see him
in "Beau Is Afraid,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-What is the room is?
-This is a room in our house,
but it's your home
for as long as you need.
My name's Grace.
[ Knock on door ]
Oh, this is Roger.
This is my husband.
-Hey, guy.
Welcome back.
Thought you'd sleep in, huh?
-Roger's a very
respected surgeon.
He's the one who dressed
and treated your wounds.
-You're a lucky man.
[ Device beeps ]
-What is --
what is this?
-That's my little
assistant health monitor.
Keeps track of your condition.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our good friend Nathan Lane,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at you!
Look at how fit you are!
-Oh, jogging over here,
I saw Tucker Carlson
in a bar chugging Bud Light.
He's upset.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no!
-He is so upset.
-He is upset.
-Oh, Seth, I --
-It breaks your heart,
doesn't it?
-Yeah. Eeee!
[ Laughter ]
You know, I see you backstage.
-Yeah.
-I thought we were doing
a podcast, but then it hit me.
This is just your "Every day
is Casual Friday" look.
-Yeah.
-And I have to --
I have to admit
that it has inspired me.
I mean, look at you. You --
You are a rhapsody in J.Crew.
[ Laughter ]
I love that you brought
normcore fashion to late night,
and with this look,
you have totally embraced
the role
of America's late-night zaddy!
-Oh, well, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much.
-You know, I --
I used to dress
like I was interviewing
with the C.E.O.
of a tech start-up,
but then you, you --
you showed me the way.
You showed me that I was
just trying too hard
and it was time
to finally give up
and embrace the joy
of the tracksuit.
-Yeah.
-I love tracksuits.
-It's lovely.
-Tracksuit.
It's fashion's way of saying,
"I have no more [bleep]
to give."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? You know,
now I can look athletic
and I don't have
to do a damn thing.
I always look like
I'm about to go for a run,
but something
more important came up.
[ Laughter ]
You know, the last time --
I was supposed to be here
a while ago.
-Yeah, but I had COVID.
We had to --
-Now, do you believe
it's real?
[ Laughter ]
And the time --
the time before that,
it was the height
of the pandemic.
There was no audience.
It was like sailing
on a ghost ship,
just me desperately
trying to make you
and three cameramen laugh.
-Yeah.
-So -- But here we are.
-And here we are with a really,
really nice audience.
-Really nice.
-It's pretty nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We are -- We are --
We're reunited showbiz brothers
like Woody Harrelson
and Matthew McConaughey,
the greatest "Maury Povich"
episode that never was.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
-You -- I want to compliment you
on something, which is,
since the last time I saw you,
you won an Emmy, sir,
for your work in "Only..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The wonderful show
"Only Murders in the Building,"
which just a tremendous cast
and one of the best things
in the world,
which is a television show
that got made in New York City.
-I know. And with Marty Short
and Steve Martin
and Selena Gomez.
-Yeah, that's a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, it was --
It was my seventh nomination.
It was nice to finally win,
although it was
a silent episode.
So all these years, the Academy
was just waiting for me
to shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- This is
the final week of a show.
-That's right.
-You've done a lot of --
-Beautiful play.
-And you've done many
over the years.
How are you with endings?
Do you get a little bittersweet
when you wrap up
a show like this?
-Well, this one in particular.
I have loved doing this play.
It's a beautiful play
by Sharr White,
directed by Bart Sher,
and starring the wonderful
Danny Burstein
and Zoe Wanamaker.
And this is --
Yes, this is our last week.
So if you're in town,
come to Studio 54 Theatre.
And, really, because
I've been thinking,
this is probably
my theatrical swan song,
my last Broadway show.
-Now, that -- that is very --
[ Audience booing ]
That's problematic.
-Well, you see, Seth,
things have gotten crazy
on the Broadway now.
I'm sure you've read about it.
Audiences are out of control.
People are pooping
in the audience.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-They're heckling the actors.
There's fistfights, dog fights,
deliveries from DoorDash.
-No! Mid-show.
DoorDash will show up mid-show?
-Beer pong.
People are having sex,
not even waiting
until intermission.
It's a nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very hard.
As an actor, that's very hard.
-Well, the pooping is the worst.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And because it's happening
with alarming frequency
on any given night
in a Broadway theater,
the 11:00 number is two.
[ Laughter ]
No, if you're gonna --
if you're gonna crap
in the aisle, save it
for a Southwest flight.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I was reminded
of our conversation,
and I think I may have
one more show.
-I'm so glad you said that,
because we have talked about --
You know, we have
this collaboration in the works.
-"Cicada, Cicada."
-Just say it.
-I mean, the audience
wants to hear.
"Cicada, Cicada" is a show.
And we might --
We might be closer
to getting it on its feet.
Do you want to remind people
of the plot as you remember it?
-Sure. Yes.
The basic plot line is,
our dear friend,
Christine Baranski,
would play a cicada
who comes to New York,
not realizing
she only has 17 days,
the life span of a cicada,
to live her best Big Apple life.
She's befriended by a very
gregarious cockroach,
played by the great
Harvey Fierstein,
in Times Square.
And he actually resides
in the glamorous apartment
of a big Broadway star,
played by me.
-There you go.
-And I've come to terms
with the fact
that this is a version of me
with a cockroach-infested
apartment.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't like it,
but I've come to terms with it.
And a lot of the New York Mets
will be playing
supporting roles.
-Yeah.
-Now, I think first baseman
Pete Alonso would be an inspired
choice for the antagonist.
-Yeah.
-Perhaps the exterminator.
-Oh, very good.
-And we have the tagline,
"Cicada, Cicada" --
The whole town is abuzz.
So...
-There you go.
-...aside from not having
a script,
I think we're 90% there.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the big news is
that I reached out
to two of my oldest
and dearest friends,
Marc Shaiman
and Scott Wittman,
the Tony-winning geniuses
behind "Hairspray"...
-Geniuses.
-And their current smash hit
"Some Like It Hot,"
and I asked them
if they would write the score,
and they said, yes, they're in!
-So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
So the next time I'm here --
I have another movie
coming out this summer.
The next time I'm here,
so it'll be very soon,
it will be --
if we work out the billing
and all the deals go through,
it'll be me, Christine Baranski,
Harvey Fierstein,
and the New York Mets
in the act-one finale of
"Cicada, Cicada."
What I'm saying is,
start sewing the costumes now.
-I am so excited.
Your enthusiasm for this is --
It's incredible to me.
-I can't wait.
-You mentioned you have a movie
coming out this summer.
You have this --
You know, we showed a clip
of this movie, Joaquin Phoenix,
the great Amy Ryan, another
"Only Murders in the Building"
alum right there.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And this director has done
some of the trippiest movies
in recent years.
He did "Midsommar."
He did the fantastic film
"Hereditary."
-Yes.
This is his third film.
-This is his third film.
This is very cool.
And, I mean, a sort of
out-there plot, would you say?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
I would say it's --
You know, look, it's --
I'll be honest, it's --
I think it's
an extraordinary film.
And I think he's -- he's
an astonishing young director.
But it's been
a divisive film.
You know, it's --
There's been a lot of chatter
about the fact
that it's three hours.
And as I like to say,
it's not a prostate exam.
It's --
[ Laughter ]
It's the --
You know, it's a unique
and challenging
cinematic experience.
And for those who want that,
there it is.
-And there's less
of that every year.
-Oh, I know.
-So I embrace that.
-Because I mean, you know,
a $15 ticket
to see Joaquin Phoenix emote for
80 minutes would be a bargain.
To see him do it for 100 minutes
would be an even better deal.
But what if I told you, Seth,
you got Joaquin Phoenix,
the greatest actor
of his generation,
for 80 minutes
and then 100 more minutes
for the same low price?
[ Laughter ]
-That's fantastic.
-And at no additional charge,
you get Amy Ryan,
yours truly,
Parker Posey, Patti LuPone,
and I'll even throw in
Richard Kind.
-Richard Kind?!
-Richard Kind!
And a Perfect Pasta Pot.
You'd probably say
it's too good to be true.
And you'd be right.
There's no Pasta Pot...
[ Laughter ]
...but there is Richard Kind.
-Richard Kind.
-And so
it's a pretty sweet deal.
What are you people
waiting for?!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-One more time for my friend
Nathan Lane, everybody!
"Pictures from Home"
is on Broadway at Studio 54.
"Beau is Afraid"
is in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with Congresswoman Katie Porter.